taliban fighters rolling through kali
ignore
the capital of baghdas province in
northwestern afghanistan
they claim to have briefly taken control
of the town
the first provincial capital they've
attempted to overrun
since the u.s and nato withdrawal began
baghdas's governor says government
forces pushed the fighters out of the
city
although not before they broke into the
region's central prison
and rescued these taliban fighters
over the sounds of heavy gunfire the
armed governor had this message for
afghans
i want to assure our people that all the
security forces including the special
forces are here and defending the city
of kala inor
the enemy who is engaged with us in some
parts of the city is facing resistance
and also facing a lot of casualties and
defeat
the afghan government has lost
significant territory in the last two
months
it's relying on airstrikes to retake
control
the ministry of defence says its troops
have killed more than 2
000 taliban fighters in the past week
brothers and sisters there is no deal
and no will to surrender
there are two choices either to live
with dignity or to live with insult
today is the day of honor dignity and
support
but if the taliban thinks that we are
surrendering to them that will never
happen not in 100 years
local militias have joined forces with
the afghan military to bolster their
ranks
this district in northern takar province
fell to the taliban last week
since may 1st the taliban has more than
doubled the number of districts it
controls
to approximately 200 or half the country
most afghan security forces are deployed
on the front line
but we militia forces also stand with
them
and defend in takara most of the areas
and districts have fallen to the taliban
now we have created several lines to
stop the taliban
reaching the city the taliban offensive
has regional allies concerned turkey and
russia have closed their consulates in
the region
while iran has restricted its consular
activities although
tehran did host a meeting between
taliban leaders
and some senior afghan politicians
back in baghdaes taliban fighters pushed
out of kalainoor
were ordered to wait at the city's gates
until security forces surrendered
day after day the pressure builds with
less than 20
of afghanistan now controlled by the
afghan government
charlotte ballas al jazeera